esto sudaneses se han estado preparando
durante varios días denuncian El golpe
de estado de abdelfata alburham que tuvo
lugar hace un año
[Aplausos]
desde este suceso los activistas
prodemocráticos se enfrentan a
represalias semanales y el domingo
pasado un manifestante murió por una
bala de las fuerzas de seguridad
sudanesas
no queremos compromiso político no
queremos asociación con el ejército no
creemos negociación no estamos aquí para
discutir El golpe queremos derrocarlo y
para ello estamos dispuestos a pagar el
precio incluso con nuestras vidas
el 25 de octubre de 2021 el jefe del
ejército el general arbujan detuvo a los
dirigentes civiles con los que había
acordado compartir el poder dos años
antes desde entonces 118 personas han
muerto en las protestas
al mismo tiempo el país vive una crisis
económica y social sin precedentes el
precio de la canasta básica ha aumentado
un 137% en un año y más de un tercio de
los ciudadanses pasan hambre el pueblo
sudanés está muriendo de hambre no
acepta nada de esto estaremos aquí el 25
de octubre estaremos aquí el 30 de
octubre todo el mundo se manifestará en
todas las ciudades el régimen del
carnicero al burján caerá un año después
del golpe militar en Sudán siguen
existiendo muchas incertidumbres y
ningún observador prevé Que las próximas
elecciones prometidas para el verano de
2023 puedan llegar a celebra